it is great to be joined today by Ken
Gwyn who's the CEO of Republic crypto I
think this will be a very interesting
conversation
ken I don't know exactly where to start
because there's so much that we could
discuss but I guess maybe for people who
aren't familiar with what Republic does
let's start there what is it that
Republic crypto does and sort of what
problem do you address within the space
mmm
first of all thank you so much David for
having me it's you know it's really an
honor and really exciting to be here
well Republic we launched two years ago
to allow everyday people irrespective
your income or net worth to invest not
buy a product but actually invest in
startups and so in the past year as
crypto assets got the global excitement
but the law is changing and crypto
assets by and large are also securities
so we expanded the platform to allow for
token sale that is legal and compliance
but open to everyone anywhere any
networks so let's explain that a lot of
people might not know that in the United
States there are certain investments
that in order to participate in you have
to be what's called an accredited
investor and correct me if I'm wrong can
I believe that that means you have
either or both a two hundred and fifty
thousand dollar a year income and a net
worth of a million dollars do I have
that right absolutely and just to give a
concrete example here David everyone
knows Facebook when Facebook grew to be
a platform of hundreds of millions of
supporters and people those supporters
wouldn't able to invest in Facebook not
only when when IPO people were able to
invest right so the law changed recently
so that people can invest in earlier
companies and that means that they get
they gonna get to participate in the
upside return of that investment so that
sounds great however to play devil's
advocate
we know that ICO investing is volatile
and
carries a significant amount of risk so
one could argue that it's actually good
to protect individuals who don't have a
net worth of a million dollars or an
income of 250 thousand dollars from
investing in these icos right someone
could make that argument
what's the counter-argument right in
other words why do we want anybody to be
able to invest in what are admittedly
very speculative projects of course the
answer is twofold I'm sure they're more
but they're too many reasons right first
of all people don't realize that
everyday Americans spend over 80 billion
dollars in lottery ticket and lose not
spend lose over a hundred billion
dollars at the casinos most of them are
non accredited investor so to say that
that's okay to do that but that you
gotta be millionaires to invest in in in
early-stage companies is a little ironic
but second one which is more important
when the Lord changed legislature and
Congress put the burden on platforms
like Republic so that we would curate
credible projects and mitigate that risk
for everyday investors so to give you an
example out of over 3,000 applications
we selected selected less than five
dozen companies to feature on republic
sis to for the credibility of an
intermediary to look out for investors
interests and quite frankly the notion
that a small dollar amount investing is
something that everyone should do okay
so let's talk about now you're sort of
getting us into what it is that that
Republic does so in a sense you are
vetting projects that people could
choose to invest in this is obviously a
major issue within the world of icos
it exists even outside of icos in
startups right which is due diligence
what are the metrics what sort of
information is available for somebody to
make an informed decision so what is the
sort of framework that Republic has in
place for vetting any particular project
we take a
lenz in that we look at the credibility
the market size the potential of a
business then the founding team do they
have domain expertise and then last but
not least is the idea easily
understandable to to the crowd is it of
interest to the crowd so based on those
varying factors the internal team would
make the decision whether or not to
accept a company to launch a campaign
and Republic and fundraise what's the
difference between Republic and a random
website that assigns a score to I cos
the like everything in in the word of
services and products I think
credibility matters a great deal
we ourselves our startup and the world
that our team came from we spend you
know decades in venture of combined
experience we have like over four
decades legal experience so our network
and our past experience give us
I think access to credible deals and
also the ability to vet projects that I
think is second to none one of the
concerns that I get from people when we
talk about the crypto space and I cos
they use the word scam and sometimes I
think that there's misunderstandings
about what we mean when we talk about a
scam so I'm curious about your opinion
on this when I think about a crypto or
ICO scam I actually am NOT super worried
about a project that's just going to
raise a bunch of money and then
disappear with the money period I think
that really the bigger concern once you
get away from out-and-out sort of scams
are projects that are either overly
ambitious and unlikely to ever really
bear fruit projects that are too big on
promises but don't really have the team
or skills in place to actually ever put
together the product that they're
promising talk to me a little about that
like when you hear about an ICO scam are
more worried about people who will just
abscond with money or do you have more
concerns about just the failure to sort
of accomplish what it is they set out to
do when I hear the word scam and I do
think there are some more than people
know
I do think of outright bad intention
projects that will launch without an
authentic intention to build and grow
and deliver a product but that leaches
raising capital and use it for four
purposes that that that's other than
then told to investor I do think that
out of that world of true scams ICO
investing or early stage investing is
highly risky the risk of you losing all
of your capital is very high whether 60%
80% 90% is high it's very high so
investing a smaller amount but diversify
your investment into a number of
companies that you think you know may
represent the potential of the future in
terms of technology in economy is the
way to go it's very difficult to bet to
make one bet and have any reasonable
assurance that's gonna work out what do
you think is the long-term trajectory of
I cos now that we've seen I guess we
could call it a correction a medium-term
correction and the values of some of the
major Kryptos there's this idea that's
floating around that it's sort of over
for crypto that the $19,000 Bitcoin
price that now is you know around six
thousand US dollars is proof that the
space is doomed the counterpoint to that
is well now hold on a second one thing
is the value of some particular crypto
assets separate from that is the future
of using a token to capitalize a company
and that that may well be here to stay
do you have a strong feeling one way or
the other on that I do and I am long on
both size and what I mean by both size
is this
there's the crypto assets particularly
the more mature one you know the Bitcoin
II cerium of the world and then you have
the underlying technology that can be
leveraged to for many companies to use
an issue in the future more crypto
assets even if you look at the existing
the traditional did the decor everyone
knows about by now bitcoin ethereum in a
good portion of the population have
invested but that percentage is still
quite low it's hard to say whether it's
ten percent of the US population or is
it five percent but I know that the
number is very small but everyone knows
about it so even under long term
fundamental of the value of an asset
like bit point of a currency like
Bitcoin if you see more and more people
gaining the confidence to put a trigger
and make that first purchase I really
think that there's gonna be volatility
with any asset but if you look out ten
years and twenty years I'm actually long
on the value of e theorem in Bitcoin
being higher than what it is today or
even higher than the most recent high
peak that we had then on the technology
piece you know here is something that
I've been in venture in in fact in
financial services for well over a
decade the word venture capital never
managed to gain the adoption of New York
City much less around the world and then
overnight even the fun of funds in Qatar
and Singapore and Sydney and London
everyone is looking into and deploying
capital into this new technology in
asset class and today the net worth of
all cryptocurrency large and small is
far less than the value of Facebook one
single company I happen to think that
this is going to be more important than
the internet itself and we had not even
six minutes into into this new economy I
have sort of a two-part question as far
as red flags and risks so before we talk
about individual project risk what do
you think represents the greatest threat
to the future of the crypto
space is it network capacity is it
regulation user adoption like what do
you think the one factor that would have
the most influence in either destroying
or elevating the crypto space is two
factors in my opinion would slow down
the growth the adoption of a blockchain
in general and I don't think anything
can destroy it because you know the
second largest economy that is China had
tried to band right a trading practice
and even that they were unsuccessful
it's here to last the question is how
fast can can it grow a 19-2 things would
would impact negatively that adoption
the the scams that you had touched on
earlier if we see more of them and
higher profile then I think that he's
going to slow down the rate of adoption
naturally and regulation is very very
important I see oh that word means many
things people can on their own website
try to raise money and most likely that
does not comply it if and then their
process see that you collaborate you try
to fit into the existing legal framework
and then you try to work with regulators
to modify legal frameworks to provide
for investor protection and all of that
so if that dialogue breaks down and you
see laws being passed in a way this s/t
or a mature that will have drastic
impact on the growth and traction of
this industry overall okay and then at
the individual project level
what for you when you're analyzing a
project would you consider to be the
biggest red flag and I'm thinking along
the lines of doesn't have to be one of
these things but you know plagiarized
white paper team that is not anywhere
close to competent compared to what it
is that they want to do it right so like
whatever whatever you look at what is
the biggest red flag for a project also
have two main flags that I usually look
for it when I analyze a project you do
the things about why people
being sounding vaguely familiar all of
those are important but the two things
that are most important one is East an
authentic useful it is a project or
company just slapping on you know crypto
a blockchain to fundraise and capture in
the Syst area or is there an authentic
functional use of blockchain technology
and the second one is how thoughtful a
project is thinking or planning out
their token selves their structure the
token economics I'll give you an example
it can be a very credible team but if
the team is an inexperienced team one
minor legal misstep it may seem minor
today but tomorrow may result in a
thousand lawsuits from investor day-in
day-out they're not gonna they're not
gonna survive for very long right so the
thoughtfulness of the team and they can
use vendor advisor if they don't have
that core expertise in-house but how
they plan that out as well so the
authentic use case of distributed ledger
I think I did two key factors to look
out for we've been speaking with Kenwyn
he's the CEO of Republic crypto you can
find out more using the links in the
video description can are such a
pleasure to talk to you today it's going
to forward to TV on your podcast and
have this dialogue David